Béatrice qui veut de la paix la paix et
ce soir j'ai envie de vous rappeler elle
va un peu d'humour aussi peut-être s'il
vous plaît
mais moi je veux que dans l'équipe ça se
ressoude pression non mais ça se
ressoude comme un bilboquet
drôle d'image
à son bilboquet
[Rires]
calme-toi parce que il y a beaucoup
Mathieu qu'avez-vous à nous dire après
ces révélations
alors Cyril Mathieu je suis très surpris
de la part de Béatrice qui est une fille
intelligente ça part ça part bien quelle
est aussi peu d'autodérision et surtout
si elle n'a pas d'autodérision j'ai une
seule question à lui poser qu'est-ce
qu'elle fait dans cette émission parce
que elle a quand même du
échapper que dans cette émission moi je
suis le mec qui a fait WAF wouah wouf
wouf est capable incapable beaucoup de
mental pour être animateur lui il c'est
les blagues tout le temps lui
l'alcoolique lui il est cocu
[Applaudissements]
physique Delton Johnson
[Rires]
que j'aime beaucoup aussi qui fait des
analyses politiques mais ce que je
voulais dire par là c'est que on sait
tous à peu près qu'on a la carrière
qu'on a en vrai on va être très honnête
si on serait pas forcément là on serait
là voilà mais rien n'est très grave moi
je veux dire un truc moi moi moi je vais
vous dire un truc aujourd'hui je le dis
quoi moi je ne pourrais pas être à votre
place parce que c'est un autre talent
dans son livre c'est un autre talent
donc je n'ai pas et je l'ai souvent dit
c'est beaucoup plus dur pour moi d'être
chroniqueur animateur je pense vraiment
je vous jure que c'est vrai parce que
vous devenez du contenu à chaque fois
moi j'en ai rien à [ __ ] je me dis
n'importe quoi non mais c'est vrai non
mais vraiment donc je vous le dis ne
croyez pas je crois c'est une énorme
talent d'être un très bon chroniqueur et
je dis juste la Béatrice que je crois
que si les gens nous aiment bien ils
nous regardent le soir c'est parce qu'on
se prend pas tellement au sérieux rien
n'est très très grave on a la vie qu'on
a la carte qu'on a parfois on dit
d'énormes conneries parfois on dit une
chose plutôt intelligente et voilà il y
a rien de très grave je pense
et voilà et je dis juste alors je dis
deux choses à Béatrice la première c'est
que si je l'ai blessé je m'en excuse
parce qu'une blague qui blesse c'est une
mauvaise blague maintenant je dis aussi
à Béatrice et là vraiment je me permets
de parler pour toi bébé Béatrice si tu
n'as c'est à moi oui Béatrice si tu n'as
aucune autodérision et là vraiment je te
le dis pour toi sinon l'année va être
très longue arrête TPMP parce que c'est
la base de cette émission j'ai fini
un pied devant l'autre comme disait
Jean-Pierre Mader Béatrice
[Applaudissements]
on va appeler Béatrice qui est derrière
le rideau c'est impossible
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît Béatrice
Mathieu c'est dire ça apparemment dans
un film en tout cas on peut aller très
belle elle est très belle et puis
vraiment tu peux aller rien de mauvaise
non si tu es drôle tout passera
Béatrice ma chérie tu as entendu ce qu'a
dit Mathieu
tu as vu qu'il a fait un pas vers toi
etc
je suis pas d'accord avec ça il faut
dire la vérité parce qu'en fait le
principe de ce jeu c'est il y a que la
vérité qui compte n'est-ce pas ouais
mais fais gaffe quand même
[Applaudissements]
tu vois non mais j'ai pas envie de faire
un plan de relance dans l'émission
les sentiments global
Béatrice déjà est-ce que tu as quelque
chose de négatif à dire sur moi
alors c'est bon tu peux y aller
[Applaudissements]
le grand jeu de Mathieu c'est de laisser
penser que les vannes sont pour
l'antenne pour faire rire la galerie et
que tout ça n'est qu'un qu'un grand jeu
et qu'une grande façade en fait quand on
voit les les trucs de Sacha et le base
les images de Sacha le les masques
tombent et on voit qu'en fait Mathieu ne
joue pas la méchanceté pour ça il
faudrait avoir du talent pour être
acteur ensemble
depuis le début de l'émission il disait
pas bonjour Il est désagréable immédié
à mon père